[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's the first thing I want to know
last time uh Giannis was here there was
a
there was a fight you say probably might
go where are the dogs
um I just basically
um took this is root spray
and I'm basically I'm essentially in
blackface I like it yeah so I tried to
get might as well finish it
I just got this brown root spray I'm
really pushing it okay sorry I'm just
trying to get because like I have these
hair extensions in now when you I put my
hair up you can kind of see my scalp and
it kind of is got some chemo energy so
I've used this to spray hold on yeah it
just looks like a strong hairline now
but look now it looks like I Hold On
come on
got it hold on now I just look like can
I tag on your head coal miner hi looks
like you're yeah graffiti there we go
okay can you see it right there though
yeah but yeah I mean you know I think on
camera they won't pick up yeah uh yeah
yeah okay girls got to go through so
much what dude I never have to spray my
head
I have to be honest with you I feel like
guys in there you have a good hairline
now you're lucky yeah is it genetic well
yeah I didn't choose it yeah I think so
because I feel like guys with the
receding hairline thing is I feel like
women's insecurities are like the things
were socially constructed that are
whatever there's probably a biological
basis too for what makes us attractive
at least those things we can kind of
control right is it okay if I kill this
bug or is that one of your pets
I just don't know that's my head lice
yeah
[Music]
buddy you got a new home now
there you go
yeah I mean you know give them a little
lollipop I know I have a little bit of
an amp problem in the house and it's
getting out of control but where else
are they gonna go I mean they need
somewhere to go yeah I mean they smell
the food and they come in I've started
putting apple butter outside in a bowl
so they just have a place to go I feel
like when you you get it to a point
where you have like more than three or
four animals in your house and one of
them is a pig yeah there's gonna be the
the ants are gonna be like I think
there's like food around yeah
look he's a nice little I can't answer
look at that aren't they cool and the
way that they can communicate with each
other and get in line in is fascinating
to watch yeah you know I don't want to
get rid of them because I love seeing uh
I figured as much the only downside to
seeing an aunt is that for five days in
your head is she wakes up in the morning
you don't remember the song no do you
know it Dave Matthews
that was college for me I'm giving
myself away but that's a little bit of a
bummer because I think there's a
hike up your skirt a little more oh that
was a good one too there's like a little
girl yeah yeah there's a couple songs
there's like uh the the he's like a real
white college act 100 everyone that was
going to see him when I was going to see
him we had the the white yarn braided
bracelet yeah and the shell necklace
yeah he's a real Virginia kind of yup it
was like sort of great Grateful Dead
Virginia Beach preppy but
yeah yeah I like we I mean I loved I
loved Dave Matthews Band Dave Matthews
Band is gray speaking of a bad hairline
he he struggled he doesn't he had that
baby bird hairline he did have that you
got yeah you gotta just shave it down
that's it so when you don't want to get
like the little Epstein Island thing
what are your options in terms of if a
guy's hair starts receding what are your
options as a man because as a woman if
you're too short you can wear heels if
you don't like your calves if you don't
have good hair you can get extensions if
you don't like your eyelashes you can
put them
what I will say is as much as you were
saying earlier it sucks being a girl
usually it's socially acceptable for us
to glue the thing on that we need you
guys really do walk around like you're
at intermission of a play no we look we
we literally can just Mr Potato Head
anything to our face and no one asks any
questions have you seen those videos now
where like uh the the woman looks like a
really different way I'm trying to be
very nice about it like contouring their
face and then like they show like the
before and afters it's like a big thing
on Tick Tock now where like they take
out their teeth and then they you know
they have no teeth there's one girl who
has no teeth teeth then she kills on
only fans yeah I mean she's not in a
traditionally attractive woman I'll say
it that way and then she puts the makeup
on and she's like stunning it is women
can do that it is shocking to me there
is a fine line between blackface and
contouring because when you contouring
is when you see girls will basically
draw these like brown zebra stripes on
their white skin and then blend it and
then they just have completely different
features right completely different face
like um Lucille Ball apparently used to
take a magic marker and just draw her
jawline wow and because of the way the
lighting was in the black and white it
made it look like she had like a snatch
it was like archaic uh contouring yes
exactly it's like it's like the CD clown
makeup yeah but anything that we are
lacking usually we can just Elmer's glue
rubber cement that shit and no one asks
any questions I feel yeah I feel like
yeah I feel like if a woman has nice
eyes it doesn't matter oh that is that
how many of these all here even in like
animals you can see you can tell like a
female animal they just have like a
there's like feminities in eyes huh that
lashes and uh yeah there's like
masculinized and feminine eyes don't you
think yes I don't know if it's even just
it's the lashes are part of it but there
is like some femininity locked in the
eyes I like that too let me ask you
though my case I this is my
this is one of my favorite things to ask
man what is the thing called that women
put along their eye lash line
how would you think there's like a zero
percent chance to answer that like the
thing that I want you okay I have no
a tiger no when a girl has a little tool
a cosmetic tool I just want to know how
hard you've tried to go out of your way
to not learn the things in your wife's
bathroom that she uses every day it's
right in front of you and you've
actively gone I don't want to learn
about that I know everything about
Hitler but I don't want to know anything
about it's drugs what my wife has in her
purse right now yeah and I don't know
everything about Hitler because I'm like
an eyelash brush that's a good guess
though if this was Family Feud I'm going
surveys that is two people said that
okay so it's a thing that goes along the
eyelash
line
uh
uh a sneaker
David Spade said Sharpie sure so I just
love okay eyelash line uh eyeliner
eyeliner brush have you heard of
eyeliner I know eyeliner it's just
called eyeliner it's called eyeliner
yeah okay and then what about that if I
came here nailed it would you be like I
think he I think he's hiding the fact
that he's a gay guy if I came in here I
was like eyeliner brush yeah yeah got it
got it got it yeah I just love there's
so few straight guys in La that are
really straight I just love talking to
them it's like an extinct species
um okay so the thing that what goes on
this part of the eye
um
blush
no
eye makeup eyeshadow eyeshadow yeah I
thought that goes underneath you're like
I thought that was a brew s yeah I
thought
I thought well that's what you put over
when you discipline your wife she puts
it over
you know and then what about the here
okay okay that is uh a backhand
yeah fist
um that is called um that's blush that's
blush that's blush yes a lot of times
guys say Rouge Rouge which is hilarious
because that's like old school like one
time I was talking to um David Spade
about this girl that he was dating he
went to a girl's places ages ago but she
came out and he's like she came out on
her second date in a teddy
Teddy is like what it's like calling a
woman that's an assistant a secretary
today right it's just like it's like
calling a car like an automobile like a
Model T it's like it was an old guy
saying that yeah like a lingerie that's
got like fur on it that's ridiculous
it's like what Peggy Bundy wore right
when they got robbed in the middle of
night and she would come down the stairs
right it's called a Teddy there are no
teddies anymore see I like people right
now the big things or can we do we say
him or her or gender non-conforming or
I'm into Teddy versus bra I like these
are the kind of terms do you do Teddy do
you do how do you sleep
um I sleep in a full suit like an Annie
Hall I I sleep I have a full Blazer on
you're ready ready you're ready you're
ready at all times oh my God I have a um
you never know when you're gonna give a
political speech okay so talk for a
second because I have a present for you
okay
hey what's up guys yeah so uh you want
me to interview the aunt or no
no where'd he go
yeah kids find me one dog or just pull
me out another dog from one of their
rooms I'm sure they're in there or a
chicken
um hey ant you forgot your lollipop
and your eco-friendly water oh here he
is so what's it like not to know where
your boys are
here's the deal what we're gonna do
don't tell her
don't tell her
yeah we're just gonna tell her that the
ant
disappeared I can't find the ant
I did not I I would never do such a
thing okay so you have the dubious honor
of being someone I call a real friend
yeah you got a good vocabulary huh you
do just now yeah dubious it's just like
in conversation that just shows like you
know okay I'm you know the car is low
over here with comedians I'll say things
I'll be like I was kind of Nefarious
people like okay two dollar word much
like okay
I don't know I don't people in this
space always say I'm smart and I'm like
if that's what it took to make you think
I'm sorry the bar is very low yes well
it's low because a lot of our colleagues
are like Community College dropouts drug
addicts and yes Freaks and just I mean
the only big word they know at this
point is fentanyl right yeah
um but uh okay so when I'm friends with
someone that I really love I get gifts
for them just if I see something that
reminds me of them and sometimes I try
to save for a holiday but sometimes I
can't now you make me feel bad though
but not getting you a gift and I come I
came to your place I should have brought
like scones or dog biscuits no that
would have felt no I don't like that I
don't like the keeping score okay in
relationship like I don't think that the
gift giving has to be Congress
pretty good word it you know I my thing
is I never expect anything back I don't
like that that score keeping stuff I
genuinely just makes me happy to buy
things when I think of people so I got
this for you at a vintage store called
Starstruck vintage when I was in
Nashville doing um the the whatever TPAC
thing this is so nice of you it's now is
this a re-gifted thing oh wow you did
think about Johnny wow it's Yanni it
does isn't that the the musician yeah
yeah it made me so happy it is you don't
have to wear it just because I was like
oh he'll just wear it to bed it's like a
stupid sleep yeah this is great so for
me I will love a shirt from a thrift
store I mean that is like a 95 dollar
shirt yes this is a vintage oddly that I
thank you very much well every city I go
to I always go to thrift stores in the
area because I love getting just because
one of my favorite things to do is get
all of the Redskins shirts the Vintage
Redskins shirts that no one else is
going to buy now that it's over but
right right because I used to always go
to Redskins games when I was a kid
you're upset that they changed and I'm
just furious yeah it's actually kind of
heartbreaking because I know I made a
whole pilot for Amazon this would lead
Daniels Lisa Kudrow about uh it didn't
end up getting made for Litany of
reasons but it was about a college
campus in Sacramento where uh the team
was called the Chiefs and it was about
how they were going to change it over
like how bad it was that that's what it
was called how racist it was and the
actual sort of granular Logistics of how
you would change something over like
that because it's a big deal I mean I
knew Dan Schneider like I know him a
little bit and when there was pressure
being put on to change the name of the
Redskins it was like yeah this is such a
no-brainer why is this even gone this
far this is wild but there's just like
so much much money in it yeah yeah just
sort of like why is this such a
difficult decision yeah but um but
anyway why don't they change it to
something like that has something more
to do with DC like the or inciting
trading Congressman or the lobbyists
this is actually something that is so
um embarrassing which is like I think
it's comics we're not the people that
should tell you how to vote or how to
live your life but sometimes we are like
I kind of got into comedy because the
things that I said seriously made people
laugh and I wasn't joking right like I
pitch I sometimes you have to be really
dumb to think of something really smart
by accident yeah and uh like I remember
there's this um guy Chuck scar writer
who ran
um Everyone Hates Chris yeah remember
that show yeah great show about Chris
Rock as a kid and they had to stop doing
the show even though it was a huge hit
because the kid was growing up
and I dead serious it was like right
before I had started doing stand-up I
was like oh well why don't you just make
everything on the set really big
[Laughter]
like a big mug like bit you know like
just like a big chair just so he still
looks like a kid and he started laughing
and I was like that wasn't a joke but I
was dead serious
but then what the Redskins thing it's so
expensive to change the name that uh it
was like if you can even keep part of
the word it would be cheaper so I'm like
just call them the foreskins and you
don't have to change the Skins part and
it's funny yeah yeah but uh so he
thought it was a joke and you were
serious I'm using usually when people
think I'm joking I'm dead serious yeah
so those are good that's a good that's a
very that's a fortunate thing when you
say something that stupid and some
people do you and you go yeah
oh my God crazy like but um okay back to
this okay what goes on here on the lips
calm
it's close to the mouth I mean here look
I told you I didn't kill him there he is
you're like what goes here duct tape
duct tape uh two fingers for a fish tank
so above the lip you're doing just like
on the lip here lipstick lip liner lip
liner and then on top is lipstick
lipstick goes on top of the lip liner
did your mom hang with you much or no my
mother was uh yeah like she would sign
the cards uh dearest mother love dearest
mother oh no sincerely sincerely she
would go love fast
mom she was like that uh with regards Dr
Anna mamalaka's Pappas and she was like
a lawyer she wasn't a real doctor but
she loved the doctor what do you mean
okay she had a doctorate in law yeah
what kind of law she was a human rights
lawyer my mother we grew up like with uh
you know uh like uh UNICEF posters and I
was on Halloween I had to go around and
get the quarters and the cardboard
little thing so let me ask you a
question what are the basic human rights
every human should be entitled to this
is a serious question I'm dead serious
I'm actually dead serious I don't think
I know the answer
you're asking I just don't yeah I mean I
don't know right to party number one I
I'm just curious what are the basic
human rights because it's like shouldn't
it be like water clean air
and
to have a podcast to have a podcast
number one to be able to have the
ability to have buckets yeah I think you
should I think the inalienable rights is
a good is a good um
start yeah you know sure life liberty
Pursuit of Happiness sure yeah freedom
from oppression you should be free to
but like Define oppression I know a lot
of women that think they're oppressed
when a guy hugs them too long well my
mother said the real challenge to
international law is culture which is
you that's the thing and you can't
that's the thing that's what makes it
tough and then if you try to criticize
someone's culture they go you're being
ethnocentric that's our culture that's
what we do but some cultures you know
the because of the religion or whatever
some would say that's a violation of uh
human rights and sure so that means is
that so not uh like kids shouldn't work
when they're like three that's that's my
mother was uh she she uh was head of
this uh ad hoc
um United Nations project called unitar
which was about the international rights
of children so she headed that up so
that was her area was children she was
always concerned about children like she
was uh there was so many times and this
was like 80s New York it's like we're
like there'd be somebody hitting their
kids in public and my mother would like
turn into like a lion and she'd scream
at them and it would be like this huge
woman and I'd just be sitting there
seven and being like Oh my God I just
wanted to disappear but that's
fascinating I love that I'm like that I
think with animals in public when people
are abusing their animals in public I
lose my mind yeah um and if you leave a
hot dog in a car I've got the hammer in
my car at all times like the kid thing
is
that the kid well it's like a thing it's
one side you're prepared yeah it's not
like the mini hammer the doctors used to
right hit your knees it's a glass one
side of it is glass cutter and the other
side is like a really sharp sort of
hammer so you can just like smash them
for the window specifically for it like
if someone's uh it's specifically for
entitled white women yo if somebody
smash cameras if somebody's about to
like kill you somebody like why don't
you grab the hammer like it's not for
that it's for the dogs
to get the breeder dogs out of the Range
Rovers um uh they didn't leave a note
um yeah that's horrible when they do
that It's Tricky the only time I've ever
intervened because I find most of my
girlfriends and guy friends that are
having kids the biggest uh issue they
have is when strangers give them
parenting advice there's a difference
between what your mom is doing obviously
like I was with a girlfriend of mine and
she had her baby out in public with us
which was I don't know why she like I
don't know but she we're outside I don't
know and uh this woman walked by and was
like you better put some sunscreen on
that baby yeah and I was like Jesus like
if I have a kid am I gonna have to deal
with notes from like straight I'm not
gonna handle that one yeah I could see
that I'm not I could see that being like
yeah that's a that would could get
contentious but one time because I'm
curious what is about like the universal
thing and what's about a personal
projection or getting triggered whatever
that word means I got emotionally
activated once when I saw because when I
see parents emotionally activated is a
great phrase is that yeah like if
someone turns you on and you're like I'm
emotionally I'm emotionally activated
and my brain is telling me I need to
intervene I am motivated to solve a
problem and get involved right it's very
rare because also like when you see
women in public with their kids and
they're at the grocery store and I'm
like
God speed like I oh I want to like when
I hear you see babies crying and um uh
airplanes now I used to kind of be like
ah here we go why do they have to fly
with your baby like now I'll send him a
drink because I'm like dude I so you're
saying you have as much empathy for
human babies as you do animals now kind
of almost it's more when it's something
that I guess I can relate to being
frustrating for example I saw this woman
in the grocery store with her like
five-year-old kid and she's obviously
overwhelmed as you know any Mom I'm sure
is she's in a something that looks like
she'd be working in like a suit or some
shit or maybe she was an actress on
going on a call back for Law and Order I
don't know it's La so you never know
right um and the kid it was this little
girl she's probably like five I'm not
great with the ages of kids like I like
I really it's hard to
I'm glad that I don't know the exact age
of what a kid is you know it's like does
it have a dream of Chrome or not no but
I know like before I had kids I wouldn't
know either three four you can't tell
you the kid was definitely young enough
to be confused and didn't understand the
Mind Game she was playing so the kid
would grab some sugary cereal Fruit
Loops put it in the grocery cart and
then the mom took it out of the grocery
cart and put it back on the shelf and
then the kid took it again put it in the
grocery cart Mom puts it back and then
the mom goes
grab it again put in the card see what
happens
grab it again see what happens
and I just was watching this and I was
like watching this kid be so confused
right I was like this is sarcasm right
which I don't think this kid understands
yet right and the kid was like I saw
like her like reaching for it she
couldn't tell if her mom was serious but
obviously knew on some level that this
was a trap or a trick or it didn't sound
right right and I just was like excuse
me ma'am I don't think your kid
understands sarcasm wow you jumped in
and I regret it Aaron did I fully
k-a-r-y-n yeah did she go mind your
business bitch oh Whitney can I get a
picture I didn't know it was you that'd
be a funny moment if she's just like oh
wait that's Whitney Cummings it is weird
when people kind of abuse their kids in
order to get a photo like can I get a
picture and the kid is just like
floating down the aisle in the the cart
I'm like but I enter I felt so
embarrassed and bad but at the same time
I feel like she was so flustered and
overwhelmed but I know that moment left
a mark because I remember as a kid I had
a really hard time with the cognitive
dissonance of of people going like I'm
fine right no I'm fine so what happened
so then I just was like I'm so sorry
that was none of my business and it just
was like awkward so it just came out it
was just like you didn't even think
about it it was just like a natural
reaction I just felt protective it's
like the way that I feel with the animal
because animals are voiceless they can't
send emails I just insert myself because
it can't stand up for itself and I think
I'm just you know standing up for it but
like this was a kid I don't know I know
what the fuck so you saying if an animal
could write an email would be able to
voice grievance more effectively like I
know you're abusing something that's
voice this I was like I don't know how
parenting works like I'm a comedian was
this something from your childhood that
was like a trigger point I think maybe
because growing up there was a lot of um
indirect communication and there was a
lot of uh sort of communication shrouded
in vagueness and uh there was a lot of
can you play salt thanks no I'm fine no
no everything's good this is great sure
no no I don't care that you're late
there was a lot of that yeah where I was
like I feel like she's saying one thing
and something or we'd go to church and
it would be like don't cheat on your
wife don't lie and then I would see that
at home and I'd be like I can't
I think kids just kind of need black and
white what I love about the human
condition and I've learned this as I've
gotten older is that so much of what we
do is not for the reason we think it is
which I find fascinating yeah it's
always like some you know trigger point
from childhood or some subconscious
motivation that you don't quite
understand we're very fascinating I was
listening
again talk about bears for an hour for
easily the third time every time you're
on Rogan you talk about he likes bears
bears and then just when I think you're
like they've talked about black bears
for 45 minutes then it's like well
grizzly bears man so then you start them
just from these people yeah no no no and
if you're gonna fight a grizzly bear and
then I'm just like I actually am
enjoying listening to this it is it is
fascinating but the perfect amount of
boring yeah because and not boring
because like two of my very good friends
people I find fascinating but it's sort
of like I kind of heard them talk about
it before it's okay it was a boring part
of the episode but you're saying I'm
listening yeah I'm listening to it I
could listen to anything I want and I'm
enjoying it there's a comfort in just
hearing my friends drone on it's like
being at the comedy store and guys being
like who would win a fight between a
wolf and uh a saber-toothed tiger and
then they're just arguing I don't know
man Sabertooth they can circle like how
many wolves is the wolf in heat uh is
the wolf neutered how old is like
there's something soothing about just
listening to men figure shit out I think
Rogan's podcast is one that if like a
caveman got unfrozen and was able to be
animated it wouldn't shock them that
much when you turned it on if he turned
the other ones on he'd be like what's
this there's a gay guy yelling what's a
gay guy what's this oh my God what's the
camera but if you turn on rogans he
would be like bear eat it you get sick
if you don't cook it at a certain time
he'd be like this is my wheelhouse he's
a caveman is what I'm saying I enjoy
listening to men
think through dangerous scenarios
because is it hot to you to listen to
someone talk about killing a bear
does it pull on some sort of Primal
female what makes you emotionally
activated Whitney
um
in the cereal aisle no but I think
there's a primordial suit there's a
soothing nature of listening to men try
to figure out how to handle the
wilderness
you know what I mean it's like this dog
if you're gonna fight a dog you have to
do this this dog will do this this has a
wolf Instinct and if you're gonna kill a
bear you do it this way like this is
what men should be thinking about at all
times how am I going to protect myself
how am I going to fight Predators you
know I'm hunt eating elk meat it's men
practicing protecting and surviving
right which we don't have to do at all
it's millionaires that have security
guards talking about scenarios they'll
never be in right right you know so but
in my case thousand error yeah it's like
uh it's like um you know there's uh some
evidence that we actually sleep more
deeply and go into Delta sleep if we
hear dogs breathing next to us sleeping
with dogs can help you sleep more
interesting because on a on a you know
it makes more sense that I'm all into
that you know I believe that protection
and you you know and that would help you
feel safe enough to sleep more deeply
but like I'm not sure what primordial
um urge or need women talking for three
hours about like suits
it would maybe um it would be about uh
breastfeeding or cooking
cleaning
we're going all the way back right so if
the guy's killing a bear the wife is
putting logs in the fire we're probably
cooking yeah cutting things up cutting
things up strategizing honestly really
and I'm not saying that gossiping is
gossiping which is a form of bonding yes
and it is soothing to watch women gossip
because that means they're more Tethered
to each other and it means that when one
of them have a baby the other ones will
be invested in the baby and the baby's
life is more than soothing I would say
hypnotic I've watched my wife watch Real
Housewives and there's such a blank look
in her little brain for us is verbal MMA
oh we're watching fighting we're
studying right right right oh wow that
could have been a bet you may want to
cut that and put on stage that's very
funny
I mean I think I'll be fine yeah I think
you got enough I think I'll be okay yeah
thank you though but yeah that's a good
one though yeah that's real mad woman
has a good observation I've only seen it
three times every now and then if I say
something that's like kind of
interesting I was like well you got to
do that on stage yeah other side I'm
like well I could also just be
interested in the conversation or funny
that was very funny I know I know I
would have said that if you were
blindsided I think you're being
inappropriately defensive oh you guys
let's talk about garbage no I'm not
talking about your ex I'm talking about
actual garbage there's a place to put
your trash that is actually going to be
good
for the Earth if you want to start
making a positive environmental impact
or just make cleanup after dinner that
much easier and by the way not have ants
all the time loamy is perfect for you
head to loamy.com Whitney and use the
promo code Whitney to get 50 off your
loamy that's fifty dollars off when you
head to
lomi.com Whitney and use promo code
Whitney at checkout food waste is gross
loamy is your solution with the holidays
just around the corner loamy will make
the perfect gift for someone on your
shopping list no joke I am getting
the people I love Lomi you it's it's
this it's this cute little bubble like
it's a bulbous little baby little egg
kind of thing and you put your trash in
it and then it turns it into
nutrient-rich dirt that you can then put
out in your yard to nurture the next
generation of your is it Flora or fauna
uh Flora Flora
don't mansplain me
manscape me
tis the season to load up on manscaped
products so you get your man your dad
your brother and friends the best gift
of all the manscaped performance package
4.0 so manscaped is a total game changer
you guys know this about me I will not
go down on a man unless he has manscaped
himself unless he has used all of the
above products the shampoo conditioner I
love this body spray by the way I
actually use this for myself oh God it
smells oh it smells so good it just
smells like a clean man that like
doesn't have a chain wallet
I just love it so much it just smells
like a man that doesn't own one v-neck
smells like a man with good credit I
just cannot get enough twenty percent
off with free shipping at manscapes.com
Whitney get your man a gift you'll both
enjoy the gift of manscaped his jingle
balls will thank you your chin will also
thank you
because I would have said the same thing
to a guy I would have said that's a good
bitch yeah no well I'll just steal it
but that is what we're pleased but
that's a good luck uh I think there's
that and because it's true you're right
it's kind of like that's how women fight
that's also why we love murder because
we're studying to protect ourselves we
have to study murderers we have to study
crime scenes that's why we love Gray's
Anatomy because it's like look getting
researched to make ourselves feel more
safe and to prepare for the imminent
threat yeah so when you watch like real
housewives you're going like nice jab
here she comes what oh that this one's
good it's kind of yeah oh shit she's
down
you're watching Lord of the Flies yeah I
mean you're watching the alpha you know
them all sort of uh uh position for that
right I love that War I love the passive
war that women wage
what's it like is everything double talk
is everything sort of uh fake compliment
phoniness the hardest part about it is
you can't prove it so if a guy Punch If
Rogan punches you in the face you can
prove it I refuse he punched me in the
face there's his wedding ring scratched
it's here when a woman injures you it's
hard when you're re verbally like that
or emotionally in a way that's kind of
um Insidious like you're saying this
kind of Silent passive aggressive
fighting when you try to recap it to
someone else you sound crazy right and
many times that's layered I love it and
many times it's very hard for men to
pick up on so have you ever been on a
double date with your wife and you in
the she's talking to the um your
friend's the wife or whatever you're
talking to the husband and then she gets
in the car and she's like what the fuck
was that why did you make me sit there
with that she was being so fucking rude
to me she was being so you're like I
thought you guys were having a great
time absolutely like how did you not see
how rude she was yeah when she told me I
look so much prettier without me makeup
you didn't notice that yeah like
remember that like so it's like fighting
happening on a frequency that I can't
access
right wrong right now we're on like our
sixth housekeeper and the last one got
fired because and I think this quote is
pretty accurate she thinks she's better
than me
and I'm like okay when and how did this
happen and she goes trust me she does
it's a tricky one she goes trust me and
I go can you explain it
no I can't just trust me it's that's
it's a feeling I get so does the
housekeeper also help rear I don't pay
attention to that at all okay no she
does not help The Offspring no huh there
is a I think inside the home the same
way a man can throw his dick around like
uh okay so let's say you're in your home
and uh you have a gun in the house okay
just to protect your wife whatever let's
just say and then Rogan comes over and
picks up the gun he's like oh this is a
bullshit gun like you're not even able
to protect your wife and you're hardly
gonna be able to you know in front of
your wife there's something kind of
emasculating about that right right
right yes I think when you're in the
home and a housekeeper or something is
like oh no you don't do it this way you
do it this way like the bacon grease you
can't pour it down you have to hold the
bacon grease out and let it Harden and
then throw it away if someone did that
in front of my man it'd be over but
can't can't we just Overlook that like
what's why does that start a war and
then we're on our sixth housekeeper well
I think it's because it I I mean I your
wife is I like your wife she's the best
yes and she chose you and you chose her
so I'm already on her side I think that
when you're in your home everything
outside your home is so stressful yeah I
I respect someone that is like not in
here how many housekeepers I have to
like I've had the same housekeeper for
16 years she is my family her name is
Leslie we've been together for 16 years
she lives here a lot of the time like
she's like my I cleaned the house
before she comes over well my wife does
that too and that doesn't make sense
even I do it just because I love her and
I she's seen me go through so much and I
want her to know that I've learned from
my mistakes and grown and matured it's a
this is a 16-year relationship and I
attribute a lot of My Success to her
because when I was in Jesus Christ like
seventy thousand I'm gonna hold you
through that when you get your next Emmy
or an Emmy I want you to thank your
housekeeper thank you I owe it to you
Leslie Leslie I but this is like a weird
little life hack that I've never talked
about because it feels embarrassing and
like white woman there you go something
new to talk about elitist yeah she um oh
yeah to start telling secrets and the
embarrassing stuff you gotta do it it's
what happens
never mind let's talk about my
hemorrhoid like it's burn it down um I
uh
when I was living in a studio apartment
right next to The Comedy Store I was
like 70 000 in debt
um no success on the horizon really but
I I had written a couple pilots and I
like taught myself to write I got a
cleaning lady before I had before I had
health insurance nothing because I knew
I was like I know my OCD cannot handle
things being dirty I had cockroaches in
this place like it just was like a whole
thing and I got a cleaning lady she was
my cleaning lady I mean literally 16
years ago when I had absolutely nothing
wow yeah before I go invested in head
shots health insurance the HPV vaccine I
got a cleaning lady because I knew that
I knew at a very young age I need a wife
I know I need a wife right behind
Evergreen woman is another woman who's
helping make sure that I don't have to
deal with like cockroaches and laundry
and shit what is the madness about
cleaning for the housekeeper though I
don't get that because my wife does that
she goes we got to straighten up the
house keeps coming I'm going like isn't
that what we're seeing her to do I let
makes me like her more because it's a
little disrespectful to just be like I'm
gonna make it as shitty as possible just
because the housekeeper is coming so
it's sort of like showering before you
see a hooker it's just it's sort of a
nice thing to do just because first of
all I'm like I just wanted to guyize it
let me just I'm like 90 sure hooker's
not the going term oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry I believe it's Street horse oh
okay I believe it's trollop what is the
PC word sex worker sex worker doesn't
sound all Sexes work yeah sex worker
that's sometimes these more Progressive
turns don't sound more Progressive no
it's like it's like the on the
temporarily unhoused yes instead of
homeless I'm like homeless people are
like this isn't temporary yes where I'm
homeless now it's uh uh incarcerated
person instead of inmate and you're
going like that's they sound synonymous
to me I don't know this is getting crazy
I just you know that's like a thing now
yes there was one recently someone tried
to term me I'll remember what it was oh
my God I'm almost there I'm almost there
hold on
oh I was um getting interviewed by this
very PC
person like the the queen of the this is
what you say and this is how you say it
and if you say it wrong you're trash
type of person sort of the new uh super
minority bully
the person that complains that they get
bullied because they're this really
unique minority there's very few of and
then they use that power to bully the
people that are actually on their side
and you'll never be good enough nothing
you'll do will ever be good enough like
that kind of person the people that
intentionally misunderstand what you're
saying on purpose to justify being
offended that's their Raz on detron and
that's the only
um yeah that's the only value they have
is being offended and making you feel
like shit so so we were talking about
something and I was like uh we were deep
into like program recovery talk of like
codependent recovery 12-step programs
like how to you know develop self-esteem
stuff like that and I said
um I said uh you know I learned it took
me a long time in recovery to realize
that just because I have confidence it
doesn't mean I have self-esteem so like
comedians I think we were talking about
what's going on in comedy right now and
I was like you know I get very confused
because most people go like you're a
comic that must have meant you're
traumatized and abused and like you must
be sad and depressed and then they throw
bottles at us and they punch us on stage
because they say we're bullies that are
causing violence and we're punching down
it's like which is it you guys it's very
like you know that we're all sad clowns
that are suffering and something bad
will probably happen to us and then
you're now saying like which it's very
and then I was like you know I think a
lot of people think comedians you know
might be tougher than they are because
we come off very confident because we do
the scariest thing on the planet right
you know the thing most people are
afraid of so maybe that's when they
conflate confidence with self-esteem
kind of thing and then I said something
about you know I was like oh I learned
that you know in order to build
self-esteem you have to engage in
esteemable action so you can't just sit
around reading quotes from Oprah and
brene brown that say like believe in
yourself love yourself accomplish things
yeah you have to do selfless like ask
your old neighbor if you can take his
trash out every day go go to the grocery
store for your elderly neighbor like do
something for someone else besides
yourself oh be of service that's how you
build self-esteem I thought you built it
by achieving things for yourself no no
by making money and fucking tens that's
yeah yeah isn't that what it is I think
that is that where confidence comes from
well it depends I think it like for me
it if you don't have the self-esteem and
you achieve a lot of stuff you might
then just go I got lucky and then you
have imposter syndr and you're like I
don't deserve anything I have or and
then that's when you see a lot of
successful people that are still
radically insecure and yelling at people
and being assholes those people I think
that means that they're genuine people I
think that they have real talents yeah
that you think the people who don't have
that feeling ever like sociopathic kind
of yeah I think that if you know you
went all the way around the track and
did it right like you know people are
always like
um if I ever I'm like yeah I'm insecure
about this or like do you have imposter
syndrome I'm like no ever there's this
new trend where people just say they
have imposter syndrome I think they
think it makes them seem smart I have
the opposite I think I deserve more than
I have I don't think I have enough based
on how hard I worked I'm like I do not
feel like an imposter I've worked my
fucking ass off I'm not gonna do this
fake humble like I have imposter
syndrome like I don't feel like I
deserve any of this like did you ever
feel it like ever at all you know there
were definitely times in the beginning
where I felt like I got opportunities
that I didn't deserve yet because it's
not even about what you got but just
like you felt about your about the craft
like not even like what you're getting
you know you know like just like about
the craft or like it's a weird feeling
you're good I felt it where I'm going
like am I a comedian like sometimes I
can be like am I a comedian I'm like
that's a weird thought yeah I'm about to
get on stage and I'm like what's that
yeah it is shocking I mean I said this I
was just in Sacramento punchline this
weekend working on new material like in
smaller venues and I came off stage and
every time I come on stage I realize I'm
like I have no idea how I just did that
yeah that's sort of what I'm saying no
idea hi I mean the Confluence of habit
adrenaline it's my thing whatever but I
always look back and I'm like whoa that
was fucking ballsy like that was wild
you know so I'm I'm still in awe of what
we're able to do on stage
um but the only times I've ever felt
weird about it is when I feel like I had
like a cheap low-hanging fruit thing or
you know a crowd a crowd work moment
that just gets more than it deserves but
that's our magic trick I think
everyone's kind of jumped a shark at
this point I think it's a very small
group of people and they uh were are
Amplified and we are exaggerating how
many there are and it just feels bigger
than it is this is why I love touring is
that you go to you see how reasonable
most people are most people have the
same thought we do they're like
everyone's lost their mind people have
got off the deep end you know it's the
inmates running the Asylum but I think
like 99 of people are reasonable yeah I
think so but everywhere you look there
seems to be a little jumping in the
shark going on I think like you turn on
the TV or you get on the internet you
see like the vice president singing the
wheels on the bus go round and round and
then you see AOC being like listen
listen listen all right listen she's
like at the Met Gala in a seventy
thousand dollars
on a commercial and then you see uh
DeSantis doing a top gov commercial
where yeah yeah dressed like Tom Cruise
yeah
lecturing people
I don't know it's gotten to be a lot I
think Donald Trump gives a speech first
thing he does is call Nancy Pelosi an
animal you're like her her husband just
fucking got hit with a hammer could you
wait a couple of fucking days to call
her an animal you're the former
president of the United States where is
the little bit of decorum I'm just
talking not calling her an animal the
bar's pretty low like the smartness on a
comedian but I will say nothing
surprises me for a couple reasons so
it's like the first thing they tell you
to do when you go into the Al-Anon
program or ACA adult children of
Alcoholics is study alcoholism and
that's the only way that you're not
going to take someone's addictive
behaviors and addictions personally
because we think like we think
everyone's drinking at us we think
everyone's overdosing at us or having a
sex addiction at us it has nothing to do
with you so for me I feel really lucky
because the way that I started in
television is I just I I needed to know
how the business worked because I was
like I know I'm not going to be the
prettiest I know I'm not going to be the
luckiest I know I'm not you know I don't
have any connections to the business so
many people that make it I mean Nicholas
Cage is related
a lot of brilliant people out there with
better hairlines that weren't going to
get that opportunity so I was like it's
not Daniel Day-Lewis I know that my
chances of making it are so small I have
to study the business and figure out
what I need to do to make them have to
hire me right like that's so I studied
the business I went on this website it's
called who represents.com I learned
every agent that represented every
person I studied all these people's
careers I was reading hot every morning
I would walk up from the apartment I
lived in right next to The Comedy Store
and steal my neighbor's variety and walk
around and read it and drop it back off
I did this every morning for eight
months until the owner of the house
finally came out and went are you
stealing my variety and it was Malcolm
McDowell and it was the scariest moment
of my life and I said to him I was like
can I please just read it every morning
I'm trying to learn about the business
you know so I
think once you learn the business
everything becomes way less surprising
because the people like Trump study the
business more than anyone he knows
exactly what he's doing he knows exactly
what to say in order to get pick up this
guy studied Hitler this guy studied
Silvio Berlusconi I did that um
wondering podcast called bunga bunga
about are you seeing a lot of yourself
in Trump right now
that's what it sounds like you're going
like look it's I did a lot he's my muse
is that weird no but he was the number
one TV star in the world right before he
the guy is a media he's not a real
estate genius he's not a finance genius
he's not a business genius he is a media
genius yeah he knows exactly what to do
I mean he is the one that asked to be
roasted I roasted him on his roast yes
and I after I went up I said the most
brutal things about him I called his
wife a whore I said like you know
Melania you shouldn't have given her a
diamond ring now she knows what heart is
supposed to feel like I just slant and
then he was the entire time I started
feeling bad he would be like wincing he
was like oh
like he looked like his feelings were
hurt but he liked the attention
afterwards I went off to kind of go I'm
sorry I hope that wasn't too rough and
he went that was great television yeah
great yeah great television yeah he used
to call and pretend to be his own
publicist because there's clips of it
the irony is Hollywood made him and now
they hate him but he really is ma he's a
media creation right well the I mean CNN
none of these places could exist without
him I mean they gave him a trillion
dollars he wouldn't exist if it wasn't
for uh The Apprentice The Apprentice is
what took him from being a sort of local
New York kind of celebrity with maybe
one Cameo and all the movies yeah
remember to like a national in order to
become the president now or to become a
big political figure I think it probably
started with JFK right having to be
telegenic and then Reagan was an actor I
mean Arnold Schwarzenegger was our
governor this I mean once we went to the
televised debate it kind of changed you
know so it's like horrible Kennedy look
the Michael Jordan of getting people's
eyeballs it's not boring he's not here's
what it is he also understands that
adrenaline addiction is real so it's
like if you can give for you you're
projecting
because you're adrenaline if you can
give someone adrenaline yeah that will
produce dopamine and then they're kind
of bonded to you you know it's like when
you can't stop watching like so if I
scare the shit out of you are you
committed to me for life for life really
so if I walk in and I like I have a
knife and I hold it to your throat and
you feel it adrenaline you'll just go I
love you I just mean it's more like when
you watch men watching football you guys
are miserable you remember
the game you're miserable but if you're
winning some money but then you know but
yes but in the the the adrenaline drip
of this masochist like I used to date a
Patriots fan Jesus Christ it was like
what do you want me to kick you in the
balls every time we fuck too like this
is a this is an addiction you're
miserable uh but I learning about the
internal medicine cabinet of the
adrenaline uh phenylephylamine and the
serotonin becomes addictive that's why
addictive relationships dramatic
relationships where you fight drama gets
addictive sure you've been in
relationships when you were younger with
women where you're like this is a
nightmare and I can't get out right
right yes you become addicted to each
other and I think that that happens with
Trump people get so addicted to the rage
I call it Big rage like not big Pharma
big rage like that's why people go on
Twitter to go get their daily hit of
rage right it makes them feel
self-righteous I think I think more
people are addicted to hating them that
even like them at this point right the
thing is you're right what you're saying
is right it's 100 right it seems stunned
no not you see you keep going back to
this thing that like I'm looking at a
little girl with a little brain it's not
that it's like you're saying something
that is not typically said you're
basically hacking it and going like this
is all chemical yeah this is chemical
and you're using an allegory of a bad
relationship that everyone's been in
where you're kind of addicted to the
toxicity of it because it gives you a
chemical rush and that's the people who
love Trump that is essentially their I
think I think that's pretty profound I
think we're gonna I guess I am surprised
coming out of a little brain
all right so if you all know anything
about me you know that I'm real big on
lubing up my entire body my face every
crevice you can imagine so people always
say that I have good skin I don't know
do people think I have good skin Pat
other people think I'm lying about my
age it's hard to tell but it seems like
that it's people think I have good skin
they're obsessed with it obsessed with
my skin right I'm telling you I
constantly put oil on my face and it's
hard for me to find
the oil that is perfect
um to do what I need it to do which is
basically lubing up your body people
think like oh oil makes your skin oily
no what happens is when you put oil on
your face it makes it so that your oil
glands stop having to produce so much
oil so you don't break out as much for a
gift that will impress check out Jose's
best seller mini collection right now
our listeners get 10 off your first
order with promo code good for you at
ose malibu.com you'll even get free
samples with every order and orders over
fifty dollars get free shipping that's
10 off at osei osea malibu.com promo
code good for you this is an incredible
product I have it by my bed at all times
and then I carry it with me when I'm on
a plane I love this product I love what
they do I'm just completely obsessed
when we tour we don't get paid to do
stand up we get paid to fly we get paid
to travel right so it's like for me that
one lost me I mean you do speak fast and
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm really impressed at
how much I've been able to pay attention
and follow this but I am a little lost
in that we get paid to fly not to stand
up well it's like I'm saying if you're
going to uh uh uh Florida whatever
Orlando Improv this weekend I think of
it as like I'm getting paid to fly I'm
getting paid to travel still don't
follow going on stage I would do that
for free gotcha okay
so you're saying Your Love of the Game
would make you do that yeah like I'm not
getting paid to go on stage and make
people laugh and do stand-up I do that
for free every night at The Comedy Store
you know what I mean every like I mean
Comics No Matter gotcha that's what I
love about La comedy is you can go to
any bullshit sushi restaurant or bowling
alley and you'll see like Chris Rock
working on his Oscar set you know it's
like I still do comedy for free all the
time okay I feel like I get paid to Fly
Southwest and make six connections and
drive to rural Iowa and stay in the
that's the work part that's what feels
like work okay I'm not getting paid to
be on stage and make people laugh okay
does that make any sense absolutely once
you explain it now I got it hearing it
was a little jarring yeah yeah yeah I
think we get paid to travel right right
that's the part that feels like work is
what you're saying yes yeah you were
shorthanding it it was a little inside I
just opened it up for all your fans I
just feel like more when men get married
they just other women talking it's like
seven seconds seven seconds I am an
unbelievable listener now because my
testosterone Throne levels are down and
it's a wonderful world it's a wonderful
world to be like oh my God I heard that
whole fucking sentence was it
interesting or that no my favorite thing
about it all my favorite thing about you
and I love a lot of things about you is
how you're one of the smartest people I
know but you don't pronounce your ends
um I sound stupid it's so funny though
it's like this and I am stupid stop
you're really not you're one of the
smartest people I know there's a low bar
there's a very low bar yeah I don't know
no I'm a snob my bar is high is it so
walk me through
um this a couple things I'm really big
on asking advice of the smartest people
I know what do you think I should do you
think I should have a kid do you think I
should get married what do you think yes
yes both I think so yes
I think it uh how's Parenthood coming
it's incredible it's the best thing in
the world and I think there there comes
a point where like you've done
everything even from the most selfish
perspective most narcissistic
perspective which I also am why I think
I did it a little later and also yeah
we're career driven and all that it is
there comes a point we've just done it
and you've dealt like there's nothing
else to do you're just it's redundant at
that point and then what does life life
yeah what are you gonna do are you gonna
have another fucking fun conversation
with your friend like you've done all
the things a bunch of especially if
you're smart it feel if you're smarter
and need more stimulations like you've
done it you've done everything you've
been to clubs you partied you're fucking
other people very few people have a kid
when they're at that point I think a lot
of times they have it before they're
like okay I've checked every box I've
lived my life the way I want to live it
without a kid now I'll have a kid I
think most people do it like halfway
through and they're like I didn't get to
do this and now I don't get to do my mud
run well I can't speak to that because I
feel like I did it later so I felt like
did it yeah but don't you see a lot of
people that are like overwhelmed and
stressed and they still haven't
accomplished their goals yet or whatever
and they see it more as a hindrance
people some people but I think
ultimately it's the the reward is so
much more than than the uh work of it
and it is hard but the reward is is you
can't even describe it it's nature try
it it's it's the most fulfilling thing
you will feel in your life you will feel
and it's visceral yeah it's what nature
wants us to do no different from string
beans or cockroaches sure that's what
we're here to do we're not string beans
string beans they also reproduce yeah
that's why there's so there's all the
beans in there sure you shoot them out
and then they make more everything just
wants to propagate yeah yeah that's what
we're doing here yeah so we're animals
right
um and so we we have that same uh need
and when you do it there's a deeper
level of fulfill fulfillment that comes
and you you know we're not here to do
the stuff we think we're doing those are
personal kind of ego driven dreams of
course and those are good but then when
you fulfill yourself on the deepest
level it's a level of fulfillment and
enjoyment that you can't and you truly
can't explain it it can only be
experienced and it's as good it's the
only thing that you'll do that will live
up to the hype and more you're just like
wow yeah you know when people say that
like it's incredible it's like it just
is and that doesn't mean it's not hard
but what is good and worthwhile that's
not hard you know of course it's it's
absolutely incredible it's an incredible
incredible thing and it's humbling yeah
and uh it gives you perspective and also
it opens you up to a a whole bunch of
new shit you're starting to see life
through somebody else's eyes and you're
you're able to write a lot of the wrongs
that your parents did and keep Evolution
going and a lot of the fear in having
the kid again going back to her topic we
had earlier where we don't
um a lot of times we do things for
reasons we don't understand I think a
lot of times people who don't do it are
doing it because they had some sort of
bad experience in their childhood and
they don't want to relive it and they're
sort of seeing themselves through the
kids eyes and they're not you know
detaching there's no dissonance between
like this is going to be a new person
that's over that's not going to happen I
just I guess I'm I feel like the way
that uh and maybe it's because I do so
much animal
behavioral like I grew up really only
being able to understand animal behavior
I didn't understand human behavior for a
lot of reasons and then uh now like the
most fulfilling thing I do besides you
know stand up a course or whatever is
like Unbreaking horses you know it's
like horses that have been broken their
Spirit has been broken and then you do
it's called Liberty training a Gala and
you help them get their pride back and
their individuality back and basically
make them free again so they can you
know
that's really rewarding to me
um uh where am I going with this
um I guess I I love that you just start
going and then figure out where you go
oh yeah I never quite yeah I'm like
those you know when I'm when you ask a
guy who's cheating on you like where
they were last night like where were you
until three of them you just start going
where was I yeah where was I three and
like buying time yeah no I actually
didn't know where I was going but like I
don't I guess I just um I think you're
in the middle of rationalizing no it's
more I
that all
all self are all of the very
very uh admirable
qualities that I have came from
pretty intense adversity and I get
confused about like do I inflict
intentional adversity onto a child so
that they're tougher like I just worry
you know I mean I'm sure they're gonna
have it on their own but I'm just like
do I neglect them and leave them at
school on purpose do I get drunk
sometimes so I think that right there
you're projecting
thinking that the kid's going to be
exactly like you but if the kid the kid
maybe the kids if the kid isn't entitled
like
a lot of people
hard to watch but you won't do that
because I'm like great mom look at how
you know you're like successful tough
smart you know shrewd fucking funny
talented like for example I know it's
gonna get me hot water but it's like I
grew up poor like whatever hand-me-downs
were available is what you were you know
this whole thing of like I'm just gonna
accommodate every whim that my child I
don't think I'm gonna be good at that
you know I learned to solve my own
problems very young I learned to
um be self-sufficient very young I think
you don't have a kid
you're seeing you know for me life is
really a stop sign and an open road and
whenever you're talking about a specific
thing if you're seeing more of the stop
sign and less of the open road you can
say whatever you want you don't want to
do it if you're seeing more of the open
road and less in the stop sign you want
to do it
I have one saying something and then
figuring it out later
get paid to run stop signs not to do
standard
the drivel no yes I see you get what I'm
saying yes I totally get what you're
saying yes I guess for me and maybe this
is probably why I'll be such a good mom
because I do overthink things a lot and
it's I'm not this willy-nilly
um type of bitch but I just see the way
people are raising their children right
now or maybe it's just the people around
me and I'm just like this
useless yeah put her in Isis give her
some adversity I just I don't know I
guess it'll be fine send her to like uh
you know a child Factory in Taiwan say
work your way out who's like a famous
adopted Steve Jobs and he was a cunt
I mean he did a great thing but I mean
he was a he never talked to his daughter
what is but is
buddhistor to in
one thing that's ever been invented he
didn't have time sure I mean he could
have called her on her birthday he was
busy inventing the thing that helps us
call people on their birthday he had a
couple minutes couldn't like I just this
whole thing where we go after brilliant
people for not being a good enough
friend is so weird to me who fucking
cares dude where people like hey Ben
Franklin I didn't get a thank you card
like why are we mad at Steve Jobs this
whole takedown we're not his daughter is
he invented a thing that people would
like fuck him kill someone for this is
the only reason that I can get out of a
jam it's the only reason I can do
anything to make money I can take
pictures of my tits and send them
instantly the guy's a genius and we're
like but he ignored his daughter she
sounded like a bratty cunt to me wow
okay yeah well I'll tell you one person
who never got an iPhone and that's his
daughter she's got a Samsung for sure
she's not gonna be looking down every
time she wants to check Twitter being
reminded of her absence of the most
genius inventor of our time but he was
kind of an absent father it's like Jesus
Christ we're gonna make nine movies of
course he was right right he's busy and
we're like Elon Musk like how come he
like Jesus Christ like let them just
keep inventing the things the kids will
be fine they have a billion dollar trust
fund if you can't figure out a good
personality and how to forgive your dad
if he's Steve Jobs if he left you a
hundred billion dollars maybe it's you I
get why he didn't call you back
Jesus Christ I like you you're always
solution oriented you go hey look this
is the problem how are we gonna get past
it filled milk how are we getting past I
do not like to be in the problem I like
to be in the solution I'm not I do not
get off on complaining I don't like
complaining uh I like just getting into
the solution that's a very healthy
mentality I believe like it's happened
there's nothing we can change about that
let's just solve it what is the gift
yeah some people love to wallow in the
Pro anyone that is over 40 that is still
talking about blaming their parents for
anything right is a dud yeah and if
you're in your 40s and you're still
complaining about January 6 get over it
there was a get over it we did roast
battle at the comedy store recently uh
Jeff Ross me uh and uh Jesus trejos were
uh uh I'm it's late at night and I
probably mispronounced his name
um we're judging there was a guy that
was like in a plaid shirt and kind of
like you know schlubby looking and um
and Chevron said you look like you
stormed the capital January 8th
that was such a good joke yeah I know
I'm gonna I know I'm gonna have a child
at some point but I just I don't think I
think that I'm or people like why are
you taking so long and why are you I
think it's I don't I'm not gonna
apologize myself for making sure I'm
ready
I think some people probably pulled the
trigger too soon
I don't know yeah I mean I don't know I
just know that I was unsure and then I
did it and then it's just great and all
the things you think are going to be
problems are not problems like what you
know oh am I going to be able to still
do my career and oh am I gonna be good
better I think it's a creative person I
mean I remember Donald Glover you know
was you know as Childish Gambino he was
by the way doing stand up he was on
community he was like rapping had like a
huge rapping career it was great at it
obviously and then one day uh I was with
someone who was like sent me a link from
Fallon and he was singing Redbone on
Fallon it's like I've seen him in like a
year and a half
shirtless singing Redbone on Fallon I
thought it was Marvin Gaye I was like
who on like he was just hit this new
gear of like genius Talent like like
gave me made my nipples hard like like
he's a friend of mine like hair standing
up the chills and I was like dude what
happened and he was like I had a kid
yeah yeah and I also think just from a
real practical standpoint as a comedian
like as you age like your audience that
was with you when they're younger they
sort of grow up they're like we kind of
need you to they kind of need you to
grow with Grow With US yeah because
they're like if you're still talking
about the stuff you're connected to
younger people yeah and those people are
going to be in you because they're into
someone younger like you were right
talking about those things that they
were talking about so okay so I need to
have a kid in order to keep my audience
now now you're gonna have it I get it
now I understand
okay it'll be all for you say no more
say no more say no more how it works for
you got it yeah okay yeah you could
clearly see how you could monetize it
now and then say no more fans yes loud
and clear yes it is just
oh
[Music]
I called them in commercials I got it
you got it no problem yes yes so it is
good to keep your career going but I
also think what we're talking about
before the studying neuroscience and and
um you know just reptilian brains and
how we're designed to be raised you know
I see so many of my girlfriends and this
goes back to your wife and the cleaning
lady thing because I wanted to tell this
uh a little antidote which is a
girlfriend of mine brilliant actress
super busy super successful has a super
successful husband too had I had a nanny
and she went home one night and the
nanny was next to her and her baby kind
of just instinctively went for The Nanny
and she was like
done it was like done you know just sort
of that guilt of I can't be with my kid
all the time but what if my kid gets
more attached to this other woman and
just kind of the primordial mama bear
shit that comes out I think that I
because I was raised uh by my aunts as
well as my mom like I lived in Virginia
with two of my aunts I was raised in
kind of an unconventional way and did
you grow up in a cult uh unfortunately
not it's just uh uh and I was lived in
Virginia with my aunts like in like
middle school and high school you know I
was like the weirdo that like lived with
my aunts you know that kid in school
where you're like huh yeah and you got a
story but you you keep it close to the
chest
I've bored people to death with like
childhood stuff but it is weird yeah
yeah I could see what you yeah whatever
yeah I see it coming yeah
we're going to Idaho I'm not going to
think about it keep going don't look
back I don't want to notice it but
athletic greens probably about right
we're all running from something aren't
we but I really the most motivated
people are running I don't I was raised
by two uh horse women basically that
didn't have kids both my aunts didn't
have kids they had animals 15 dogs
horses like I saw women that were happy
without kids uh and then I saw my mom
who was overwhelmed by my sister and I
who were a problem we're you know
stressful
um so maybe I just have to like rewire
that but
the point is I feel very secure with a
child being raised by many women in a
tribe so become a Mormon you know what I
mean because we're kind of designed to
have aunts and sisters would you be okay
with a guy with a bunch of wives and
then like you know would you be one of
them
it's weird because anyone that dates me
I have so many women I do have a harem
of bitches at all times in my house and
like lit female Comics Leslie my
cleaning like you are kind of marrying
into a bunch of a bunch so you'll be
raised by a bunch of loud female Comics
that it's a very fun way for a person to
grow up you'd be a fun mom yeah but like
I would I think that I'm not I don't
feel weird and I've you know some of the
uh most educational relationships I've
been in is dating guys that have kids
and an ex-wife and the ex-wife has a
boyfriend and then the guy has me and
the kid is being raised instead of by
two great parents by four and being
exposed to like you know
all kinds of points of view my therapist
helped me understand it's just like just
make the feel the kid feel enjoyable and
that just that clicked for me I was just
like I don't have to push it I'm like I
wanted to succeeds because like just
being because I wasn't made to to be to
feel like I was enjoyable that's why
obviously I stand on a wood plank for
free sometimes yeah like enjoyable
like I what my parents enjoyed me like
I'm you seemed like an obligation to an
obligation a burden an afterthought uh
yeah me too I was the third you know so
yeah that's a big thing huge like you
don't have to do too much you just gotta
like make sure they don't die and enjoy
what they're doing you have a sense of I
know I'm already pushing it kids know
when they're like the youngest and they
were an accident because most women
don't think they can get pregnant right
after they have a kid I was a surprise I
knew I was overwhelming I knew I was
pushing it I knew I couldn't add any
emotional distress I knew that I had to
be needless so I learned to self-deprive
and I knew that I was overwhelming and
not planned like I felt it so I was like
I know I need to prove my worth be
valuable other ways and be needless
wantless and don't push it basically
right and here you are kind of thing and
I need to like entertain people and when
people are stressed out like I'm just
going to be the Court Jester that like
makes the drinks for Mama and uh does
the jokes you want everybody to get
along you want everything to be okay you
want you want to be like yeah you want
to be noticed you want to feel enjoyable
because you weren't made to feel you
weren't made you may you mean you like I
felt a little bit like a burden I felt a
little bit like a hassle right right I
think that that's probably a common
theme with a lot of comics yeah and then
by the time you're born they've already
had a kid or two and they know you're
not gonna die every time you cough so I
guess she's fine right right maybe a
little ignored oh for sure yeah there's
a reason why we do it because I also had
to learn my dad always said this and I
and I didn't value it until later he
always said it's your job to entertain
yourself he wasn't saying it in a
scolding way right is that I just
remember he would always make himself
laugh like he'd crack himself up and I'd
be like Dad what are you laughing at
he'd be like it's your job to entertain
yourself in life and it would like make
himself laugh and so I always like that
always stuck with me too because I was
like oh it's my job to entertain myself
it was deep connection hard for you with
people
um
define deep connection I don't know
you're my best friend is that weird
that would be weird to find dude
connection because I I have to be honest
with you I think that like doing
stand-up this is probably going to sound
fucked up to people but it does feel
like a very deep connection to me like
when people come up to me in airports
and they're like I saw you at this show
and then I came back inside it's all
fake yeah but I when I'm with someone in
the front row and we're vibing and it's
like so deep connection is hard for you
because here you are telling me as long
as you pay an admission fee I can
connect
someone who comes up to the airport
because here's what I'm saying this is
what I'm gonna say I don't think it's
hard for me because you know when
someone who I don't know comes up to the
airport and is like something that I've
done which is really just a version of
me trying to hide the fact that I'm
lonely and sad and they say that they
liked it because it made them not think
about their bills while they were
fucking cooking and they listen to me in
the background it feels like a very
profound deep connection very two-way
you know
selfless
it's so pure I mean that is the purest
relationship I have ever heard at gate
D16 yeah did you even catch the name of
the person who stopped you in the
airport or happened to buy a ticket in
the front row in fucking Sacramento his
name is Under Armor shorts guys that you
and him
I have to say though I have a
Heaven as I date come see me do stand up
like and this podcast the people I date
do not listen to this podcast like if
you've listened to this podcast since I
started it you know me better than any
of my friends or family members so you
do have a hard time with deep connection
I don't know are you just described it
three different ways what is the Deep
look my best friend is someone who comes
up to me at the airport and says can I
get a picture also the guys that I date
uh they don't know me as well as the
complete fucking strangers that watch
this podcast do you have a problem with
deep connection I'm not sure I don't
know would this ant still be here if we
weren't deeply connected I killed the
other one so that's gotta be a new guy
I I truly like see if he wants some
candy come here uh the fact that I'm my
candy is being rejected by an ant is
really dark I people tell me men have in
the past told me I have intimacy issues
I refute that because I'm like just
because I don't want to be intimate with
you or just like because on your terms
or whatever you define intimacy as just
because you're on Adderall and you know
this eye contact or you need me to like
be around like I just I do you scroll
while you're getting fucked I have I
have
um no I I guess I just to me sometimes
when someone is emotionally needy and it
feels like pressure to me and that's not
connection always that's sometimes just
forced
um me I believe the deepest emotional
connection I can have some someone that
gets their own emotional needs met
internally an animal
well my horse and I I do believe that
words are obstacles to connection much
of the time right so if I can connect
with someone like non-verbally and be in
Silence with someone that's when I feel
emotionally deeply connected to them
right yeah can I ask one question before
we go yeah if someone
is lying like I'm interviewing Anna
delvey do you know who she is fucking
hats off to her anyone who can pull that
off hats off she went to jail now she's
on house arrest and I'm gonna interview
her on um Tuesday in New York and I was
kind of like thinking about
is it a lie if you think it's true
you know yeah if but how do you if
there's an objective reality and then
there's a but if you don't know you know
I have some people in like my family who
it's like the pathological dishonesty
it's like I think you are lying to me
but I think you think I don't think you
know you're lying I think you think what
you're saying is true
it's called gaslighting maybe but is
that but I feel like it's so gaslighting
is like I'm intentionally going like why
why would you think that I mean well you
must be cheating well then they're crazy
if they if they're discon if they don't
know
that it's a lie and I truly believe that
it's true then you're dealing with
mental illness yeah like like there's no
great I don't think there's a gray area
there yeah I think you're either like
but there's no way to convince that
person no what's the point of being mad
at a person who's you can't tell someone
who's mentally ill they're mentally ill
I mean like we couldn't walk over to
Kanye and be like hey man I think
maybe you should open back up the bottle
of medicine yeah yeah yeah yeah you had
that's a mood stabilizer and you can't
he's like what are you talking about I'm
Jesus yeah um you know you can't yeah
you can't like have an intervention and
convince someone who's having a manic
episode that they're having a manic
episode I've been through that and it's
wild like Elizabeth Holmes just went to
jail for 11 years but the idea of like
do you think she actively knew every day
she was lying or do you think she
genuinely thought she was gonna pull
this off I'm just like the delusions of
grandeur is a very real thing for what I
know about it she was probably it was
like an intentional kind of grift right
like but I don't like I said to my uh I
went into a meeting with a giant comedy
manager when I was 23 and I said I'm
gonna be a successful stand-up comedian
at the time it was a lie now it's true
like I didn't know it was going to be
true at the time
like when we lie on our resume or when
we fake it till we make it it's like a
lie until you it's true
I see what you're saying
um like if Anna Delphi had pulled it off
those wouldn't have been lies so it's
like it's not a lie because there's no
proof to the contrary because you said
future tense yeah I will be yeah so it
actually yeah is as much true as it is
false if you had went in there and said
I am a successful comedian then they
would have went are you well where's my
commission no you're not but we're in
this weird time where it's like this
face until you make it manifest I am
getting this I am gonna do this and it's
like it's a lie in 10 years well you'll
find out if it's the truth or a lie in
like 10 years right one of those right
because I don't know how mad to be at
her because I'm like oh if you would who
are we talking about the anadelphi girl
or if home girl well she intentionally
was swindling yeah she was intentionally
uh imitating somebody she wasn't she was
intentionally pretending to be something
she wasn't but how do you become someone
you are if you don't lie on your resume
a little bit unless you have a trust
fund how is anyone supposed to get rich
in this country if you don't lie and say
you're already rich I can't because no
one will give money to someone who isn't
already rich I can't dispute what you're
saying if you're are you asking hey do
you got to be a little uh you gotta get
your beak a little dirty in order to
make a little scratch in this country
I'm gonna say yeah then that's the truth
how else are you gonna make it without a
trust fund because no one will get a
loan to someone that doesn't have a
backup money but then you can't get
money if you don't lie and say you
haven't no very few naive very good
people who are fucking loaded if that I
know very few people who are a hundred
percent fucking honest and beautiful
it's in every business person have to
like lie I mean I definitely relied on
my resume but then it became true right
you know I said I can do this way before
I could so when you have your kid
essentially you will teach them like so
now he's like okay so I changed my mind
you should not be a mother yeah
yeah
no you would actually teach him Hey
listen you gotta you know if you're
gonna play You Know You're Gonna you're
gonna go out in the world it's not it's
not all roses you're gonna be playing
with some people it's a little muddy and
you got to learn how to be a little
muddy yeah and not Lose Yourself along
the way I have these Big Dreams and the
whole thing now is women are supposed
every woman has to be a CEO now no one's
allowed to just be a florist anymore
like you have to be like the biggest
girl boss at 24 but how am I gonna do
that if I don't lie a little bit lie a
little bit so I I got in the wrong
business for that we have to tell the
truth to make money it's very annoying
but like in any other field how could
you possibly achieve anything if you
don't lie a little bit I think you're
making an interesting point I'm I'm not
I can't I can't dispute that the
evidence supports what you're saying
it supports what you're saying when this
is the deepest emotional connection I
can have a man just going you're right
that was an emotional connection I feel
great about that so just look for a guy
who just walks around and goes Whitney
you're right
when you go when you go should we get
another six rescue animals and build a
giraffe bedroom that is my life he had a
husband who goes that's a great idea how
about we get three giraffes and you go I
love you that's what you're looking for
yes so I need someone very Crocodile
Dundee yeah
yeah if it's truly yeah you just got to
marry someone who just goes for it I
know I kind of feel like I want like a
cowboy type it's tough and when you're
it's a tough thing because you go to you
go to Idaho you go to Iowa you're you're
going to Missouri you're going to
Chicago You're yeah it's tough wow I
mean you've got this beautiful house
you're probably here for like six hours
a week right yeah yeah yeah I mean you
got some fucking Ukrainian Refugee
watching the place
I really do I have like I mean I could
come live here and you wouldn't know
correct yeah I could be here it's a
couple Comics yeah
laughs every now and then I'll just like
find a pair of checkered Vans I'm like
whose are these I'm just looking for a
sperm donor and it's like the you know
what it is it's like the it's like the
Whitney uterus games like you have to
fight TV it's like I'm Helen of Troy you
have to fight if you can find me you
deserve to be The Sire of my Offspring
because I don't want no weak
motherfucker who's gonna DM me on Bumble
I don't want to interject here but it is
it does sound like you're facilitating a
stalker you're basically saying I if you
work hard enough to find out where I
live wrong with a stalker how much do
you hate yourself that someone that
wants to follow you around to shows
you're like oh fuck this guy like if
someone's stalking me dedication I'm
like why how self-loathing are we also
if you are not strong enough to fight
off your own stalker you don't deserve
to be famous
you know weird if someone follows us to
every show we think they're like Ugh you
like me do you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah well you know their like is
always like really strong in like a
scary way in like a Jehovah Witness only
us we are so self-hating that if someone
likes us we're like ah crazy stalker
they must be mentally ill right who
would want to watch me do comedy more
than once like that is such a weird
you're right it shows dedication if
someone can scale walls and kind of just
show up and yeah someone someone breaks
into the house the female comedian that
is a progressive radical feminist
someone's like I just want to hear
Whitney Cummings don't yell about men
again I mean that is the level of sick
dude though I'm like I just need to take
you in you need a hug right if you like
this is on some like oh God you would be
the one who would marry your stalker
that would also be a funny show that
like you just end up marrying your
stalker I'm so fascinated by the people
that like me everyone else is freaked
out by how into you he is except you you
know how many of my own stalkers that I
have started stalking to the point to
where lafd is like you we're not telling
you anything else because I'm just like
I'm fascinated by the kind of person who
would do this like me
you know what I mean yeah I guess maybe
I've just been so trained by comics and
comment sections to think that I'm like
annoying a shrill and unlovable that
when someone is into me in any capacity
I'm like what's wrong with you homie
like I'm fascinated by you like you guys
really hate yourself of all the people
you chose me yeah why me
it's a name you yeah yeah I think that
you would make them doubt their own
stalking they'd be like maybe yeah I'm
like how fucked up because you're like
okay you didn't hear
in any capacity you find it flattering
you I mean but they're motivated yeah I
mean it's also like also who am I gonna
date no one will guys don't ask me out
guys don't talk guys
if someone to me if I see someone that
is undeterred that is tenacious that is
like it what here's the thing if you're
a younger guy and you see a girl on a
podcast that you like and you're
listening to her you found out about her
and Rogan you're listening to her talk
and you're like I like her we think
alike that's how is that less weird to
then go to a show and ask her out how is
that less weird than seeing a girl
across the bar that you just think is
hot solely based on her tits and ass and
face and go hey let's talk and then you
she gets in your car how is a stalker
that has followed you less is how is
that a more dangerous situation than
getting in a car with a complete
stranger that you met at Senor frogs you
know what I know the argument you're
making is wrong but you're making a
compelling argument
wow
someone that knows nothing about me what
you're really getting at is the
strangeness of the phenomenon that the
more of somebody likes you the scarier
it is and why is that but then yeah but
then someone that I don't know I've
spent three months pretending I'm a
different person whereas if you've heard
my podcast you know exactly who I am I
can't hide shit from you right and I
already know that you're into the person
that I really am so you're not going to
be disappointed in three months when The
Jig Is up right there's nothing to hide
right and I also know you like me for me
thank you
I like jumping in your life men get to
date their fans if they're Comics but if
women do it's weird it's not weird at
all just because I don't know I'm in the
because here's here's the situation I'm
in
if if you're not if you don't know me at
all you're not a comedy fan and we're
probably not going to get along right if
you are a comedy fan got it and don't
know me that well it probably just means
you don't like me or don't think I'm
funny got it that's not gonna work got
it right okay now I'm understanding
what's going on what is the what's my
option I don't I'm not saying anything
I'm just trying to understand what's
going on when it comes to a show pays
money to see a female comic talk at the
end of the show still thinks she's hot
right and it's like I'd like to take you
for a drink that's the only option I
really have at this point
sounds like you really like him am I
wrong
being a the Aging female comedy it's not
about who I like and who I don't you
just have to narrow down
possible at this point because tons are
possible you're funny you're talented
you're good looking yeah but but if
someone has never heard of me that means
they're not a comedy fan right right
right I'm not trying to be a narcissist
someone's never heard of you yeah
probably they probably just aren't a
comedy fan they're not a podcast fan
we're probably already not going to get
along right right right or you are a
comedy fan and you don't know that much
about me that means you're not a fan you
like comedy but not mine right that's
probably not going to go well right
that one marry a horse
I would love to they got big dicks I
would love it too you know like what are
my options otherwise right no I'm not
critiquing I'm not saying what am I
supposed to do I'm not saying it's about
my only other option is marrying a comic
okay so yeah
okay I get it
what option do I have who am I gonna
date I mean yeah who who you like
name one person I could date name one
one um see Thomas Howell who's that he
was an actor in Soul Man and also um I
can't date actors I can't date men that
wear makeup okay
um give me someone like like literally
actually
uh real real pitch you can be a Kumar
you want to be a Kumar who's that you
know what a goodbyes no the uh the
girlfriend of a married guy who's
Italian no okay no I'm just I'm going
through a list my wife would yeah no no
no no you ever think about just I don't
do it for cool points just going lesbo
for a second I don't do Other Woman shit
in a way that's like if a guy that's
married flirts with me I will like tell
though like I'm like uh I wanna say a
lot of guys a lot of nice guys
you know but you know okay we're not
going to want to date me or they're not
going to have the the balls or they're
gonna I don't know they're just not
going to want to sign up for that you're
a lot of women
[Laughter]
calling me fat no no you know what I
mean yeah yeah a lot of person I also
have a lot I got gender I also have a
lot of comedian guy friends yes so
you're the fucking problem uh but a lot
of guys I think
at midnight when Tim Dylan calls to
complain about being kicked out of the
Airbnb because he caused a hate crime in
the comment section I'm gonna have to
fucking answer you know so a lot of my
friends are it's kind of hard today to
go and also half the guys to talk to me
I swear to God two months in they're
like so Rogan like do do you go like I'm
like you just want Joe Ro to hang out
with Joe I get that too it's very like
or you then all of a sudden they want to
start a podcast all of a sudden they're
a comedian and they're like it's so it's
like I don't know people really want to
get to that guy they're going like I
think I could be in the puck I'm like
what are you talking about are you
insane are you crazy yeah you do not
want this yeah I was like it's in it's a
bummer and also that a few of them
thought that that was gonna happen just
because they had like a like a dog
Affinity or like guys they'll be like
well I'll show you should I come out I'd
love to meet Rogan I'm like I told him
about you he already thinks you're a
pussy like he does not want to eat I
guarantee it's not happening I told him
what you do I told him what you're about
and he's makes fun of you kind it's like
an inside joke with all our friends I
get what you're saying you know kind of
like your female comic your your you
know you're you know you're you're
independent I get it yeah it's a lot
you're on the road also like dumbass is
talking about my pussy like you just you
have to be able to put up with that to
be able to put up with those stuff I
have like a lot of guys around me that
it's a very they're very close
relationships but it's like having a lot
of brothers but also my best friends are
the statistically the funniest people in
the world right so I'm if you say
something that's pretty funny I'll be
like that's funny right I probably won't
laugh right even if you're the funniest
person to all your exes you're probably
not you know right I see the challenge I
see this and I don't I stop fake
laughing at Men's jokes a long time ago
right
once I got syndicated I didn't have to
do it anymore right so uh just a crazy
psychopath who doesn't need his stuff
laughed at who's a big fan of History
hyenas big fan of hyenas big fan of
Giannis Papas stalkerish but here's the
other thing I I I used to think it was
weird when someone knew a lot about the
comedy scene that I met because it's
like you're like a fan of Comedy like oh
but then I was like no I I want to I I
at least right now I enjoy talking to
people that understand the the our
ecosystem or the subculture of us
because I don't have to explain it and I
don't feel like an asshole being like oh
well you know because
you know this guy this guy and they do
this thing so like then I feel weird
right because I'm like you're not a
comedy fan right right so right you're
at the point where now it's it's comedy
fan time I'm just gonna date my robot
yeah you could do that too
yeah you could do that too
well and also people don't ask me out
right they really don't like Greek
billionaires that run like
pages about like money motivation
sometimes do
[Laughter]
you know those like businessmen yeah
there were like five tips on how to make
money while you sleep
it's like those type of guys I know that
are like yeah comment below and I'll
give you a hundred grand yeah there's
three types of men yeah
and they have like three million
followers for no reason like they bought
all their followers and you're like I
don't know what you are you're trying to
be like the money Tony Robbins guy yeah
yeah five ways delusional narcissist
yeah five ways to make your crypto turn
into millions yeah yeah so you get a few
of those guys yeah like you know morning
routine yeah
this is my morning routine it's like
Jesus Christ yeah yeah like for butter
in my coffee yes yeah okay so I don't
want to date a guy in ketosis right I'm
not I'm not I'm not I can't even
technically single
20 minutes since the podcast started no
it's not long right not long at all all
right I need someone Relentless too
right because I'm not calling you back
all the things you're saying point to
stop if I don't Relentless back in six
hours and you haven't followed up I'm
just like right I like a predator I like
a Chase I like an aggressive I mean
everything you are saying I can only
legally describes a criminal stock I can
only come if it's a crime
you need someone who's relentless
right that's hot to me it won't take no
for an answer excessively into you
massive coming back excessively I just
mean there's this thing now and I did it
myself like you know in my you know 20s
and early 30s where it's like I'll meet
you at the restaurant and I'm gonna pay
half and I'm in like that all worked and
I'm glad I did it and whatever works for
you godspeed but I just know myself and
I will accidentally emasculate a
motherfucker like in my sleep and I do
not want to walk on eggshells because
someone but worrying that someone else
is going to be a masculine right because
he's going like you want to go to
In-N-Out burger and you're going like no
I want to someone who's solving problems
before they become problems right
someone that is just like I'm gonna
anticipate I'm gonna make your life
easier and that's what I get off on
because that's how I am in relationships
too right
yeah I see it's a challenge sometimes
for uh for women who are successful
maybe or maybe not I don't know I think
it's a challenge I don't know I don't
know I think that that
it just doesn't occur to people ask me
out or they don't think they can or they
think they have to be mean to me like
hey you think you're so funny like shit
like that and it's like cool right guys
try to be funny with me and it just ends
up being mean or they think they have to
like put me in my place in a way that's
like too rough and they don't see the
soft side of me that kind of just wants
love right I like a guy that'll just
like
choke me and then kiss me on the
forehead
you know what I mean yeah you ever think
about putting a list together and just
sending it out like yeah guys love that
yeah just going these are the things
that I need choke kissing the forehead
relentlessness you know what I also
think it might not be in someone here
like it could be an Italian guy yeah you
know maybe what if you're guys in China
Saudi guy yeah what if he's a Chinese
guy maybe yeah maybe or like a Russian
guy they're very into the you know
Outback like not the Outback you know
the Wilderness and what if you just go
spend some time in like Argentina from
Chile yeah maybe from Chile like a minor
someone that like doesn't even know what
I do for a living not has no clue but
then when fine thinks it's cool no just
someone who has no idea who you are but
is just happy to get the green card that
I like a transactional relationship yeah
I don't mind that I need to I need a
baby in some jokes you need citizenship
let's just let's do this let's make it
let's make it happen like a business
relationship yeah I don't know I just I
don't know but I do think younger guys
are very into like the the impact of
video games that a lot of people don't
focus on is the fact that a lot of these
guys that play a lot of video games they
are into that white night shit they want
to be the hero they're into the Kink of
the medieval traditional gender roles
where it is your job to protect the
damsel and they want to come rescue the
Damsel in Distress and a lot of the shit
Call of Duty all that kind of stuff like
I'm sure there's negative impacts of
video games like show me the data let's
talk but like you know it's a lot of
like I want to protect and I'm going to
kill the bad guy and protect the good
guys and then in real life they want to
keep doing that you know
like I was uh hanging out this guy that
uh we were in a hotel gym and there were
all these glass it was all glass walls
of a hotel gym and the other side was
like a glass building Like a downtown
yeah and we walked in the gym and he
kind of like like put his arms out in
front of me and he was like this room is
a tactical nightmare is what he said
right and I was like what and he was
like well someone could just shoot right
through that into this like there's no
he learned that from Call of Duty well
yeah he just was he looks he just thinks
in terms of like how do I protect her
from this and there was something so hot
about that right none of this sounds bad
none of this sounds bad none of this
sounds alarming
it sounds like the traditional things
that people are looking for
a guy who knows where all the vulnerable
yeah someone who knows where the
vulnerable points are in a room for
attack well it is tricky because I'm
like
stop laughing your real laugh at that
was really fun yeah I don't know I just
feel like if someone tries hard enough I
usually get worn down right
relentlessness yeah seriously I who can
judge I can't judge I I think I was just
seeking African man used to remember the
movies when men would show up at a
woman's work when she was halfway
through a speech again we're getting and
he'd be like I'm sorry I cheated and
she'd be like you know yeah but that's
the movies carry her out yes some movies
though I want someone to come in and be
like fuck this show yeah you're with me
right you want someone who comes in this
room right now and just sprays whoever's
in it and finds all the Tactical yeah
yeah I want someone that is just a
trained assassin
[Music]
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
think I've also never casually dated so
I'm trying to do that 40 is the perfect
time to start just casually dating 40 is
the new 30 no nine
40's young dude 40's young the arrogance
that came with the biological arrogance
that came with me freezing my eggs I'm
just like I got all the time in the
world well women it's unfair right isn't
it unfair the way Nature has it set up
it's a little unfair that's the thing
about that biology is sexist it really
is it just is it you know you can talk
about all the equity you want but when
it comes to that that can't be changed
it's like guys we just have mountains
and mountains and mountains of of
surplus sperm for our whole lives
forever dude Richard Gere has a
three-year-old he's 74. yeah it's just
remember when Clinton Eastwood had a kid
at 77. yeah he's gonna get to know his
kid for like three days but also isn't
the connection between autism and old
sperm that seems to be the I don't know
main connection to autism I don't know
there's a lot of autism out there or a
lot of people claiming to be autistic
yeah I don't know yeah but it does seem
to be
um On The Rise yeah I think that
certainly in our field and our business
I'm not sure how ubiquitous is other
places I think it is kind of yeah on the
rise yeah so is it on the rise or is it
just being diagnosed more I guess that's
always the thing right when they say
like you know cancer is on the rise well
we didn't have a way to diagnose it in
the 1800s where people dying of cancer
and we just didn't know that's what it
was right right right right right it's
hard to know it's hard to know what came
first chicken or the egg
you know someone has to have figured
that out what comes first to chicken egg
no one's no one solved that yet the
starting the starting point how have we
not we've got all we've come full circle
how have we not cracked that yet pun
intended crack the egg how do we have we
not I know what the pun was yeah you
didn't have to spell it out I just
sometimes get concerned you know
um all right I love you madly I'm so
glad you did this well I love you Dilly
thank you for having me I love you thank
you for doing this so last minute yeah
you're one of my favorite guests to have
on and you're one of my favorite people
yeah period you're totally one of my
favorite people thank you
um next time uh we'll do a big Greek
night again let's do it yeah and I love
um your new podcast is like I Love the
clips that you're posting thank you yeah
long days with Giannis peperson watch my
special if you haven't mom love yes uh
it's on YouTube it's brilliant it's free
not emotionally no
don't ride elephants
[Music]